le rendez vous était donné sur un
parking dans une ambiance calme à
l'heure du déjeuner près d'une
soixantaine de personnes ont répondu
présent au débat organisé à trappes par
la cgt 78 et l'organisation au point
retraités salariés ou chômeurs soit
faire passer leur message tenir bon
malgré la détermination répétées du
gouvernement à réformer le code du
travail par ordonnance la rue fera
reculer un jour ou l'autre même si avec
la loi elle comme rit ou on a eu
beaucoup de manifestations n'a pas fait
reculer mais il le paiera cher quand
même un moment ou un autre et la cgt a
déjà prévenu une nouvelle journée de
manifestations est prévue le 21
septembre prochain la veille de la
présentation du projet en conseil des
ministres dans le détail la réforme du
code du travail prévoit 36 mesure pour
le renforcement du dialogue social selon
le nom officiel avec notamment le
plafonnement des indemnités prud'homale
la fusion des différentes instances
représentatives du personnel ou encore
la possibilité de mise en place de
contrats de chantier c'est aussi enfin
et surtout plus de négociations
possibles au coeur des plus petites
entreprises
les accords des accords de branche et
accor disons que c'était nationaux
seront balayés pour des accords
d'entreprise
malheureusement malheureusement dans mon
co entreprise ya beaucoup moins de la
prod syndicats ou inexistants et bien là
ce sera la loi du bâlois du patron voilà
selon le calendrier souhaité par le
gouvernement les ordonnances devrait
rentrer en vigueur dès le 25 septembre
prochain